page spéciale Téléthon dans le 7 8 ce
soir durant une demi-heure nous allons
revenir sur cet événement 26e édition du
Téléthon qui se déroule les 7 et 8
décembre bonsoir à Daniel Bazan vous
êtes le coordinateur départemental du
Téléthon face à vous Daniel Tamam
bonsoir à vous présidente Téléthon à
Manille les hameaux et Freddy Bechet
bonsoir conseiller municipal à Voisins
le bretonneux première question le
Téléthon l'an dernier au niveau national
a terminé avec 86 millions d'euros de
promesses de dons est-ce qu'on peut
battre ce chiffre cette année tout à
fait tout à fait parce que sur ma
coordination je suis assez satisfait
depuis je vais dire 7 ans que je suis en
un thème de la coordination je
souhaitais battre le record des
sans-contrats et cette année c'est un
aujourd'hui on a 101 contre un
d'enregistrer dans une manifestation sur
l'ensemble du département des Yvelines
je dirais même plus parce que on a quand
même ce qu'on appelle nous des additif
par par contre donc
c'est très encourageant parce que là on
voit qu'il y a une grosse grosse
mobilisation sur le terrain on a des
villes qui étaient pas du tout Téléthon
les autres années
par exemple il y avait pas de Téléthon
sur la commune de Trappes
il y a eu du travail de fait et cette
année on a si contraints et donc on peut
dire un espoir de voir sur un liser une
très grosse manifestation en avenir et
ce qui permettrait de battre le record
donc aussi au niveau départemental
environ 400000 euros à peu près ont été
récoltés l'an dernier lors du téléthon
vous n'avez pas peur de la crise malgré
tout c'est vrai que la question se
posait déjà les autres années mais
peut-être encore plus cette année ce que
les gens vont donner je pense que je
pense qu'il y aura pas trop d'impact
parce que les gens sont généralement
généreux ils se sentent impliqués et
concernés
en tous cas au niveau de manileamo
partagez cet avis sur voisin au niveau
des voisins un gros challenge puisque
l'année dernière on était à 9000 euros
et là nous souhaiterions atteindre 10000
euros donc une progression de deux
chiffres en général il y a une
progression régulière qui se fait sur
une progression régulière mais au niveau
de voisins l'année dernière déjà mais là
nous souhaitons vraiment insuffler une
nouvelle dynamique nous souhaitons avoir
une montée en puissance et je crois que
sur il y avait le thème innové pour
guérir nous c'est innover pour donner
plus alors comment vous faites pour
impulser une nouvelle dynamique
justement pour récolter encore plus
alors pour récolter plus on a fait sous
la houlette du service événementiel de
la mairie qui est un service qui est
très innovant et très très dynamique on
a rassemblé les associations à plusieurs
reprises et ce qui s'est dégagé c'est
que il y a une on a essayé de fédérer
les associations les associations
veulent vraiment travailler ensemble et
au lieu de comme les autres années qui
avaient une succession de différentes
prestations
qui se déroulait avec des temps morts là
cette fois-ci c'est vraiment une
orientation résolument dynamique avec
deux plateaux simultanés de plateau
multidisciplinaires donc c'est à dire il
y a un tas de il y a les arts martiaux
le cirque la jonglerie les gymnases qui
vont intervenir simultanément sur le
plateau et ce sera à quel endroit
précisément pour les gens qui menaces
dans le centre sportif des pyramides et
on a également une grande surprise mais
dont je reviendrai peut-être après
la surprise alors c'est du teasing
puisque bon ben surprise on doit le
garder un petit peu c'est un très gros
flash mob donc les flashmob en principe
c'est les réseaux sociaux qui les font
là c'est les associations c'est un grand
rassemblement c'est c'est à 17h j'espère
que TV fils sera là ou l'ensemble des
associations fera une chorégraphie
ensemble
on souhaite vraiment à ce moment là
enflammer le gymnase vraiment donner une
impulsion de telle manière à vraiment de
de à faire pleuvoir les dons alors
justement la grande surprise c'est que
vous allez participer vous pouvez nous
le dire ce soir c'est ça vous serez pas
vous allez participer avec l'ensemble du
conseil municipal de voisins Bretonneux
il y a une flash mob à Manille et un mot
pardon
nous nous allons mettre en place comme
chaque année à 25 heures non-stop
d'activité de succession d'activités sur
scène et à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
du gymnase donc 25 heures qui démarre
demain 19h encore des parents une
marraine prestigieuse
on a une marraine absolument comme
chaque année cette année Virginie
Lemoine humoriste que tout le monde
connaît et puis des VIP notamment à
l'ouverture avec Delphine racinay double
médaille aux JO effectivement de Londres
de tirs à la fausse plus précisément
pour ces médailles qu'elle a décroché on
voit quelques images des animations les
hameaux notamment depuis tout à l'heure
Manille Lamot c'est une commune qui
récolte souvent beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent
effectivement il y a une grosse
rentabilité
l'année dernière en 2011 nous étions à
3,43 par habitant c'est une très très
belle somme nous sommes un petit peu
moins de 10000 habitants ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que les donateurs font
l'effort de venir au gymnase Chantal
Mauduit plutôt que de donner à distance
à part la télématique c'est la raison
pour laquelle on met tout en oeuvre pour
les attirer dans ce gymnase pendant ces
25 heures où il y a des activités pour
tous les âges et c'est difficile de se
renouveler une année sur l'autre de
surprendre un petit peu le public qui
vient vous voir on y arrive
on y arrive on y arrive avec la
complicité de toutes les associations
qui travaillent sans bénévoles 23
objectifs Téléthon maniois et puis
l'ensemble des services de la commune
sans quoi nous pourrions faire vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure beaucoup plus
d'animations que l'année précédente sur
l'ensemble du département
sans une manifestation sans un contrat
où vous nous l'avez dit par rapport aux
86 de l'an dernier ça veut dire qu'il y
a plus de personnes encore de mobilisés
ça représente quoi les bénévoles n'a
jamais été difficile d'en trouver c'est
très difficile à savoir réellement le
nombre parce que on a des manifestations
qui tournent avec 50 60
bénévoles donc c'est très très difficile
le nombre de bénévoles il augmente cette
année au niveau de la coordination j'ai
fait j'ai huit bénévoles en plus donc ça
c'était jamais jamais passé et déjà donc
on voit que le les personnes sont
mobilisées à cette cause qui est qui
marque assez sur le les manifestations
sur tout ce qui se passe en moi qui a
quand même une augmentation sur le
département des Yvelines je suis ainsi
fier de ce qui se passe
une bonne idée un ici on a parlé de
manie par les voisins également trap
vous l'avez mentionné tout à l'heure qui
a une autre commune
donc notre village d'accueil qui est
comme chaque année donc on fait un
village d'accueil sur la coordination
c'est un essai Rambouillet où là aussi
et ben Rambouillet se développe
énormément on a beaucoup d'activités
tout au long de la journée tout ça en a
le béniton qui est exceptionnel cette
année donc j'espère que ça va le chiffre
va augmenter quand on va retrouver le
chiffre de 2008 vous allez continuer à
nous parler de vos actions de cette
mobilisation juste après ce reportage
d'Anthony Reich de Guillaume camps
pardon ils se sont rendus au Généthon à
Évry là où se pratique la recherche
depuis des années grâce au Téléthon des
jeunes malades atteints de déficit
immunitaire de maladies rares du sang et
du cerveau ont déjà bénéficié des
thérapies né de la recherche impulsée
grâce au Téléthon 36 essais sont en
cours de préparation sur près d'une
trentaine de maladies
en pratique c'est dans ce lieu que vos
dons pour le Téléthon sont utilisés et
c'est ici que tout commence dans cette
pièce la banque d'ADN sont stockées les
échantillons de 83000 personnes malades
et de leurs familles notre mission dès
le départ c'était de collecter ces
échantillons de les coder de façon
anonyme pour être en conformité avec
l'acné pour la traçabilité et autres et
après extraire la matière première pour
les chercheurs pour que eux ils
cherchent l'anomalie qui est sur cette
ADN
bonjour et bienvenue à la plateforme
d'imagerie ne vous inquiétez pas au sein
de l'imagerie la lumière est éteinte
pour ne pas détériorer les cellules sur
lesquelles travaillent les chercheurs
grâce à cette équipement de pointe les
spécialistes du Généthon peuvent
comparer le comportement des médicaments
appelés vecteurs ici en vert par rapport
à la cellule en rouge et voir comment le
médicament est intégré par le patient
grâce à ses études on s'est rendu compte
que les vecteurs utilisaient les
mécaniques naturels de la cellule pour
s'intégrer dans dans le noyau et donc ça
permet d'avoir une étude plus solide et
plus poussée qui permet de comparer les
différents traitements et de justifier
des choix des des vecteurs que l'on
emploie pour soigner les patients
grâce à cette structure inédite un essai
clinique pour le déficit immunitaire à
destination de passion français anglais
ou allemand est en cours dès 2013 une
thérapie génique pour la neuropathie
optique de l'auber qui rend aveugle les
jeunes adultes va être lancé et dès 2014
un traitement pour la myopathie de
Duchenne devrait voir le jour des
processus étudiés depuis des années en
matière de thérapie génique les
chercheurs doivent s'armer de patience
les premiers résultats que nous avons eu
par exemple lorsque nous avons réussi à
guérir la myopathie du chêne chez les
souris c'était en 2005 et là ça a été
une grande avancée parce qu'on avait
réussi à concevoir un médicament qui
déjà chez la souris marchait très bien
et bien c'est en 2014 qu'on va enfin
pouvoir le tester chez l'homme l'AFM a
été créée en 1990 et financé à 90% par
les dons du Téléthon plus de 7000
maladies génétiques sont actuellement
connues un chiffre en augmentation
constante chaque année
on vient de le voir avec ce reportage
nous parlons donc du Téléthon on le voit
les dons sont bien utiliser il y a une
vraie transparence qui existe autour de
des actions qui sont faites il est je le
dis pour les téléspectateurs très facile
de se rendre au Généthon pour la presse
d'avoir des témoignages chaque année
même si chaque année ce sont les mêmes
questions en plus qui sont posées aux
chercheurs ils sont toujours très
disponibles et ça c'est une motivation
supplémentaire aussi pour les gens qui
viennent donner de l'argent ils savent
quoi va servir cet argent ils savent
qu'ils seront informés ensuite quoi
qu'il arrive de ce qui peut se passer
oui bien sûr nous leur disons et parce
que nous le croyons déjà nous sommes
convaincus que la que les dons sont
utilisés à bon escient on vient de le
voir et potentiellement tout le monde
est concerné c'est 5 millions de
Français
pas loin c'est c'est énorme c'est en
conséquence de quoi je pense que déjà il
y a des ions
les les personnes qui viennent faire un
don sont sont convaincus qui qui faut le
faire et puis savent en conséquence ou
valargens quand on voit ce que coûte la
recherche ce que coûte un microscope
électronique c'est 300.000 euros
c'était énorme effectivement elle est
donc important de donner vous partager
forcément cet avis lorsqu'on écoute
Daniel Tamam sur cette transparence et
ça facilite aussi le fait de donner
c'est un argument supplémentaire à aucun
moment il y a eu il y a eu un doute même
par exemple chez les bénévoles des gens
qui sont partis qui sont dit voilà la
recherche avance mais elle avance pas
assez vite
et sur l'invisibilité des comptes c'est
vrai qu'on est très clair là-dessus et
ce qui est tout à fait normal que
l'inconçoit ainsi stricts l'argent quoi
on parle de la motivation des bénévoles
vous nous avez dit vous êtes depuis 7
ans à la tête de la coordination du
département c'est ça vous avez commencé
quand vous engager pour le Téléthon par
exemple
je me suis engagé pour le Téléthon à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux en 87 et chaque
année vous avez été présent pour que je
suis sur le terrain et donc depuis que
je suis à la coordination
c'est de plus en plus quoi mais enfin
cette année je compte ça a été très dur
quand même
pour
faire rentrer des contraintes tout ça
bon j'espère que la remontée se fera
voir un peu plus vite ma main et que
cette année les choses se passeront
mieux en tout cas pour donner alors je
rappelle aussi le numéro de téléphone le
36 37 qui sera ouvert dès demain
vendredi matin vous pourrez faire vos
dons jusqu'au dimanche soir et puis
ensuite à partir du lundi jusqu'au
vendredi ce sera entre 9h et 18h mais
n'oubliez pas le 36 37 et puis les
différentes manifestations pour donner
directement je vous laisse rappeler
chacun donc les rendez-vous principaux à
quelle heure vous allez débuter la
manifestation sur Manille nous démarrons
à Mani les hameaux au gymnase Chantal
Mauduit à 19h demain vendredi 7 et nous
arrêterons 25 heures plus tard samedi 8
à 20h et du côté de voisin nous
démarrons demain donc à 19h et nous
arrêtons dimanche à 19h merci et nous
pédalons tout le long l'année dernière
il investinois qui a pédalé 115 km et
chaque kilomètre pédaler donne droit à 1
euro et je vous l'ai signé enfin je
voulais conforter une chose que vous
disiez au niveau des services techniques
qui s'engagent énormément et je crois
qu'il faut le rappeler les services des
villes sont vraiment très très engagés
aux côtés des bénévoles et c'est eux
également qui nous permettent de de
faire tout ce qu'on fait puisque on sait
que il faut tout faire en régie merci à
vous trois d'être venu sur ce plateau
donc pour témoigner sur le cette
opération du Téléthon 26e édition on va
continuer à en parler sur ce plateau
avec deux nouveaux invités pour
l'instant on va vous écouter c'est vous
qui avez la parole allez-vous participer
à cette édition on vous écoute
oui probablement oui oui comme tous les
ans bien entendu
peut-être oui tout à fait et même on va
faire une à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines une action au
niveau de la fac de droit avec la
session juristribue donc je vais y
participer en donnant en faisant un don
mais aussi en faisant une action parce
que c'est un
on dirait c'est un événement important
pour la recherche contre les maladies
dites orphelines je sais pas encore mais
je vais participer
à différentes manifestations qui qui
sont organisées par la ville de Montigny
j'ai participé d'ailleurs jamais je
l'avoue
je fais un don d'argent même si j'aime
bien donner directement aux gens
concernés au lieu de pas donner par
association parce qu'il y avait
plusieurs fois déjà de problèmes